alors s'il vous est réuni aujourd'hui
c'est parce que c'est bientôt noël et je
pense que c'est très bien qu'on crée un
nouveau produit dérivé
vous n'êtes pas chaud c'est face à ces
que les produits dérivés on les a tous
fait déjà pas tant que ça les parapluies
les chaussons leslie plée cartables les
bougies et aussi les coussins et d'y
aller même des sextoys et c'est pas une
blague ça existe vraiment mais je sais
j'ai essayé mais non non je pensais
vraiment faire un truc énorme
[Musique]
un jeu de plateau mieux que ça un jeu de
société
bah c'est exactement la même chose
comment pourrait s'appeler cette botte
de je sais pas mais je pense à un truc
un peu fou un jeu je me lâche un peu
harry potter à l'école des sorciers
la boîte de jeu donc on en a parlé tous
ensemble pourquoi est ce que la boîte
s'appellerait forcément harry potter pas
parce que c'est mon nom en fait mais en
fait ce serait bien de mettre en avant
quelqu'un d'autre parce que c'est tout
le temps toi ouais c'est vrai ça arrive
tu désolé mais t'es pas tout seul dans
l'histoire tu te souviens ok harry
potter à l'école des sorciers harry
potter et la chambre des secrets
il va quand même pas et le prise tous
les faire dans harry potter et la coupe
de feu tu remarques pas un truc là ça
ressemble à martin
on pourrait faire par exemple des trucs
à lamartine harry potter va la plage
harry potter vers les tartines harry
potter fait cela s'est vu
non mais tu as raison peut-être un peu
changé on peut la paix dragon dragons et
l'échec des ventes de la boîte de jeu
écoute c'est pas pour être méchant mais
c'est vrai que tu as un peu pris la
grosse tête
alors excusez moi d'être le pérou en
fait de la saga en fait je n'ai pas
choisi ses je suis désolé mais depuis
l'épisode 6 a un peu changé mais le 4 ok
donc tout le monde se ligue contre moi
c'est quoi c'est la révolution sinon
pour mettre tout le monde d'accord
la bonne méthode à l'ancienne on peut
demander au choix peau au mari potter
forte note épique flou les utiliser pour
que ça bouge un peu plus jeunes ce truc
là il ya 150 ans à ça ça ne veut rien
dire bon évidemment dans la boîte de jeu
j'imagine qu'on pouvait mettre toutes
les maisons de poudlard a donc les fonds
d'or
serpente à
certains excusez moi vous avez oublié
pour que souffle ah oui mais en fait on
n'a pas dit mais on a fait un sondage
est en fait les pauvres souffle l'ours
en bas les couilles et sondages c'est
tout c'est souvent la vérité
alors oui à la baja poudlard d'il y a
quatre maisons plus d'ailleurs c'est
quoi ton prénom totalité qui y figure en
16 de l'épisode 4 ah ça va pas être
facile à porter comme un prêt dans ça
sinon on pourrait faire en sorte que
jamais prononcer son prénom d'un jeu
impossible c'est déjà mois bon bah tant
pis on t'appelle joyent je préférerais
figurants 16 ouais donc on disait dans
la boîte de jeu le contenu pur et dur ça
pourrait être
on pourrait mettre des potions genre
branchies flore filtrer la mandragore je
te rappelle que c'est quand même un jeu
fait pour les moldus en longueur et mgi
font pas de magie est long et bolduc
sarsgaard tpm paix et des vidéos sur
youtube où le gars il mange bleus
pendant 24 heures avant était dévolue
quoi vont même au spectacle de danse sur
scène actuellement la cigale et bientôt
dans tous les zénith de france
l'affiché actuellement ici les places en
espagne dans la description ok donc pas
de magie j'imagine que ça veut dire pas
de quidditch non plus à cécilia des
moldus qui font du coup dit et là ça
ressemble à ça
[Rires]
di cule les boues seront bon bref on
fait un jeu de plateau de d'aurillac
waialae score il ya des personnages des
fiches de personnages aussi c'est
comment score à moi sur ma feuille de
personnage de toi mon score sur ma fiche
quoi ta ta ta fiche de personnage est
évidemment à temps je peux dans le jeu
ainsi si tu étais dans le jeu par contre
dans les remerciements
mais ces débours remerciements c'est
vraiment la famille il ya tout le monde
à l'horizon les autres torrent enfin
pour le but du jeu un peu comme dans les
films dans les livres
imaginez qu'on pouvait éventuellement
devoir tuer qui on sait qui on sait qui
on sait il a un nom quand même ce tome
elvis g d'user moi mais c'est trop long
très très long
sinon j'avais pensé aussi lisse bah non
c'est impossible tu vas pas d'appeler
elvis n'y a qu'un seul elvis est séduit
ouais et roméo elvis alors bref on
disait que le but du jeu ça pourrait
être contenue en fait tout ça couvre pas
ouais ouais non en fait je trouve
justement je trouve ça un peu relou déjà
à chaque fois je ferai le méchant à
chaque fois je meurs à la fin
normalement et amis ta gueule c'est quoi
cette mentalité de merde là c'est délit
de sale gueule mais vive la france bravo
c'est bien continuez et vous
l'encouragez way et petits détails tao
situer mes parents c'est vrai et c'était
il ya longtemps et crois bien que je le
regrette maintenant qui dans la vie n'a
jamais dérapé
emile louis francis troy c'était des
bois c'est bon hockey et ben c'est
parfait on a tout ce qu'il nous faut une
belle croix de jeu pour les moldus qui
s'appelle une année à poudlard
c'est bon c'est cool tout le monde est
content allez pose des chaleurs ou alors
partir j'aimerais vous dire un truc
c'est vrai que
j'avoue je suis très souvent mis un
petit peu sur le devant de la scène sur
moi qui suis dans la lumière mais cette
aventure c'était pop et bain et l'aurait
jamais été possible sans vie donc y aura
plus jamais de produits dérivés qui
s'appelleront juste harry potter
peut-être juste le peignoir harry potter
non les pneus on n'a pas fait les pneus
de voiture l'a raconté un sens des pneus
est bas dans ce cas là les piles les
piles harry potter existe déjà en chine
ben voilà ils m'ont encore ap et l'école
les copains
[Musique]